Hallo Wolfgang. Hallo Stefan, wir stehen in der Garderobe, gleich geht's raus
für den Live-Salon und wir haben ein buntes Programm zusammengestellt,
denn wir starten erst einmal mit einem Statement von Stefan Raab und mit einem von Heino,
aber keine Sorge, es wird jetzt nicht nur um Unterhaltungsfernsehen gehen,
ganz im Gegenteil, wir widmen uns dann nochmal diesen Diskursen um die Superreichen
und was da zu tun ist und du bist ja dann doch jemand, Jemand, der,
wie mir aufgefallen ist bei unserem vergangenen Podcast, sehr gegen Blühdorn gewettert hat.
Ja, kommt mir sehr bekannt vor, gegen Blühdorn zu wettern, weil das absolut
richtig und notwendig ist. Oder gibt es da schon wieder Widerspruch?
Naja, ich würde dir ein Alternativprogramm vorstellen, das in meinen Augen auch
keines ist, nämlich das von Hedwig Richter und Bernd Ulrich.
Das müssen wir mal ein bisschen kommentieren. Darf ich mich jetzt schon geschlagen gehen?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. und dann hast du dir diese tolle Sendung angesehen, die 100.
In der ARD-Sendung ging es darum,
ob man die AfD als demokratiefeindlich branden sollte oder ob das doch eine
ganz normale Partei ist und Bürger haben mit abgestimmt.
Ich dachte mir, wir als große Fans und Vielsprecher der Idee von Bürger retten,
gucken uns an, was die ARD darunter versteht.
Da dort auch eine Konfrontation stattfand. Gucken wir das, weil da sind wir
ja sensibel, wir wollen ja Konfrontation.
Ohne Schläge natürlich, wie die ARD das gemacht hat.
Und ansonsten machen wir eine kurze Medienwirkungsforschung anhand dieses Materials.
Und du willst mir heute einreden, dass Inhalte wirklich keine Rolle mehr in
der Politik spielen? Das wird interessant.
Ich greife unseren Clip auf, den wir selber produziert haben.
Du forderst Inhalte für kritische Betrachtungen.
Ich habe dir ja widersprochen, werde heute nochmal zeigen, wie sinnentleert
Inhaltslehrpolitik ist.
Dann mache ich eine 180-Grad-Wende, erkläre, wie man die Inhalte wieder reinholt,
um kritische Betrachtung, wie du sie zurecht forderst, zu ermöglichen.
Und dann kommt eventuell nochmal eine 180-Grad-Wende, je nachdem,
wie du dich auf das Argument einlässt, wie man diese Inhalte zurückholt.
Also ich möchte, das kennst du vielleicht, wenn du mit kleinen Kindern ein Spiel
spielst, das viel Gewinn teilt. Da gibt es die, wie heißt sie,
die, wo man nicht mehr rauskommt, die Zwickmühle.
Man muss sich dann für eine der beiden Seiten entscheiden, also man kommt nicht
raus, der andere hat sozusagen zwei Alternativen und man kann aber nur einer widersprechen.
Und mit einer solchen schubst du mich heute rein. Genau, ich will dich heute zwickmühlen. Gut.
Wir enden dann mit etwas Kuriosem, nämlich gibt es eine ZDF-Sendung,
die hat Boomer mit Gen Z konfrontiert.
Und wir fragen uns mal, gibt es überhaupt noch ein Erkenntnisinteresse oder
worum geht es ja eigentlich?
Wir wollen aber auch noch ankündigen, was wir im Salon lesen.
Und zwar gibt es da ein neues Buch, das kommt jetzt in den Tagen raus.
Das heißt Gutes Geld von der Ökonomin Philippa Siegel-Klöckner.
Dieses Buch hat eine Buchpremiere erlebt mit Micky Beisenherz und hat einen
Blurb von Giovanni Di Lorenzo. Manche werden sich jetzt schon fragen,
ist das vielleicht das schlechteste Buch der Welt?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, denn es ist ja eine sehr anerkannte Denkerin.
Wir hatten sie irgendwann auch mal bei Wohlstand für alle im Interview,
ist schon eine Weile her und dann ist auch Michael Hüther von diesem Buch angetan
und es ist ja eine progressive Ökonomin und es ist ja höchste Zeit über Schulden,
Geld und all das noch einmal anders zu reden,
zu denken und das ist wohl eine Einladung, dieses Buch.
Aber ich habe dir ja auch schon Clips von Michael Hüther, der hat ja einen Podcast
mit dem Chefökonomen des Handelsblatt, Bert Rürup.
Er kommt auch langsam ins Lager der progressiven Ökonomen. Man glaubt ja nicht,
was man so sieht. Es ist jedenfalls nicht Clemens Fuß, sondern Michael Hüther.
Also das ist die Salonlektüre, die große dann.
Und Stefan, du hast dir aber noch was vorgenommen. Du willst im nächsten Salon
noch etwas lesen. Ja, heute ist der 19., das heißt morgen oder übermorgen kommt
der neue Gegenstandpunkt, da habe ich gehört, das lesen die Neomarxisten.
Die Planungsfetischisten, die Neue-20er-Kritisierer. Und ich dachte mir,
wir klopfen die Zeitung mal ab auf die Gegenwärtigkeit und die Dringlichkeit
ihrer Argumentation hinsichtlich der Debatten, die wir haben.
Und ich will nochmal sagen, wir haben gerade eine Debatte zum Thema Superreichen
in Büchern, in Fernsehen. Und ich suche ja nach Zahlen.
Ich will es ja kristallisiert haben. Und der Gegenstandpunkt soll ja jetzt mal liefern.
Nun, ich habe ja Gegenstandpunkt hin und wieder gelesen und würde schon mal
in Zweifel ziehen, dass das, was du da suchst, da drin stehen wird.
Aber vielleicht kaufe ich mir die neue Ausgabe dann auch, damit du nicht so
ganz ins Blaue hinein kritisieren kannst, damit du ein gewisses Korrektiv hast.
Denn Gegenstandpunkt in meinen Augen ist ja vor allem ein Medium, das Staatskritik übt.
Da geht es also gar nicht so sehr um die Superreichen. Geht es schon los mit den Ausreden?
Mit den Umwegen? Wir werden das alles dann im Salon besprechen.
Und diesen Live-Podcast und auch all die anderen Salons kann man hören, wenn man uns abonniert.
Das geht am allereinfachsten über Steady.
Man geht auf neu20er.de, dort ist ein goldener Button,
da kommt man gleich auf die Steady-Seite und ab drei Euro im Monat kann man
dann die Zusatzformate hören und natürlich auch ins Archiv steigen und dort
all die alten Folgen sich anhören.
Und es gibt aber noch andere bequeme Möglichkeiten, zum Beispiel für Apple-Kunden.
Genau, wenn man bei Apple sowieso schon, also über den Apple Podcast Player
unseren Podcast hört, taucht die einfach auf und dann kann man auf den zahllos
richtigen Button klicken.
Patreon für diejenigen, die Accounts dort haben. Unser präferierter Weg ist
aber der Steady-Weg, der ist auch am günstigsten und am vollständigsten.
Das ganze Archiv, alle, was weiß ich, 100 Bücher, die wir jetzt gelesen haben
seit Januar 2020, kommt dahin.
Bis gleich. Bis gleich.
Hallo.
Guten Abend.
Wolfgang quietscht.
So, wir sehen Wolfgangs Frisur das erste Mal bei uns in Real Life.
Wie viel Aufmerksamkeit wollen wir heute drauf legen?
Reihe 1 rastet aus.
Ja, die Menschen sind begeistert. ich bin es auch vor allem,
dass ich die Kappe nicht mehr tragen muss.
Ja, sehr gut.
Erleichtert mir das Leben. Normalerweise beginnen wir immer mit einer Frage,
aber du hattest heute gar keine Auflage. Oder möchtest du doch was?
Doch, ich habe eine Frage, denn Wolfgang hatte gerade eine These.